la inseguridad alimentaria aumenta en el
mundo según un informe de la
organización de las naciones unidas para
la alimentación y la agricultura fao
193 millones de personas no tienen
suficiente para comer cada día
vemos una situación en que las cifras
relacionadas con el hambre aguda han
aumentado de hecho a un máximo histórico
y concretamente tenemos un aumento de
unos 40 millones de personas en
comparación con las cifras de 2020
unos 139 millones de 24 países donde hay
conflictos prolongados se han visto
afectados por el hambre aguda los
territorios más aquejados son afganistán
república democrática del congo etiopía
nigeria sudán del sur siria y yemen la
crisis económica en pakistán y haití
también ha puesto en riesgo de hambruna
a su población
las familias vulnerables no pueden
acceder a suficientes alimentos para
comer todos los días
como resultado tienen que emplear
mecanismos de supervivencia de
emergencia como vender activos saltarse
las comidas involucrarse a veces en
comportamientos muy peligrosos
los cambios climáticos extremos cada vez
más frecuentes son otro factor de
preocupación 23 5 millones de personas
de 8 países africanos se vieron
afectadas en 2021
somalia en el cuerno de áfrica se sitúa
entre los 10 que están en riesgo de
crisis alimentaria en este 2022 no hay
agricultura debido a la sequía que ha
devastado a nuestro ganado incluyendo
cabras cuando ellos y vacas y la gente
se enfrenta a la peor crisis humanitaria
no hay flujo de agua en el río y
afrontan una grave escasez de agua a
pesar de los esfuerzos de la fao que ha
puesto en marcha un plan de respuesta de
ayuda a los agricultores en somalia como
dar a los campesinos semillas tolerantes
a la sequía o transferir dinero a los
más vulnerables la falta de lluvias el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
y la persistente violencia amenazan con
poner en riesgo de seguridad alimentaria
aguda a unas 6 millones de personas